[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live.
Temos uma live hoje muito especial. É
com grande satisfação que eu dou
boas-vindas aos nossos convidados dessa
noite para uma conversa que vai ser
excelente, vai ser muito esclarecedora,
que promete expandir horizontes dentro
da visão da saúde integrativa. Então,
tenho comigo o Dr. Lucas Pacheco, que é
médico homeopata, ex-professor da
Faculdade de Medicina de Pouso Alegre e
o Dr. Lucas tem se destacado pela
aplicação do homeopatia em vários
contextos complexos. ele vai falar aqui
pra gente, ele vai se apresentar ainda
com mais profundidade. E também nos
acompanha o Dr. Luiz Sterne, querido
amigo, também médico formado eh pela
Faculdade de Medicina Souza Marx, é um
dos meopatas mais atuantes aí do Brasil,
que tem assim um conhecimento muito
vasto, vasta experiência hospitalar, atu
por vários anos em diversos hospitais no
Rio de Janeiro, continua atuando em
UTIs, ele também vai aprofundar na sua
apresentação aqui. Então, nós temos aqui
duas figuras aqui que tem uma
experiência, um conhecimento muito vasto
dentro da homeopatia. Então, uma honra
tê-los aqui conosco. Então, ambos
compartilharão as suas experiências
práticas com visto com álbum e outras
terapias homeopáticas em contextos que
vão desde a oncologia até a terapia
intensiva, demonstrando como a
homeopatia pode dialogar com a medicina
ortodoxa ou com a medicina ortomolecular
de maneira complementar, de maneira
muito fundamentada. Então, será uma
noite de aprendizado de troca de
experiências clínicas reais e longe de
dogmatismos focado na prática médica
responsável.
Muito bem. Por favor, se apresente, Dr.
Lucas.
Dr. Lucas, pode se apresentar, por
favor, para nossa audiência.
Nossa audiência.
Microfone tá bloqueado. Microfone tá
bloqueado.
Boa noite a todos. Muito obrigado, Dr.
Alan, Dr. Luiz Sterne, eu sou Dr. Lucas
Franco Pacheco. Eu sou médico homeopata,
eu coordeno a pós em homeopatia da
Present Educação, já fui presidente da
Associação Médico Homeopática Brasileira
Jovem, já fui também diretor da
Associação Paulista de Médicos
Homeopatas e já fui professor da
Faculdade de Medicina de Pouso Alegre. A
gente tá aqui hoje para lançar com muito
carinho a mentoria em homeopatia. Uma
mentoria avançada. A gente selecionou
300 casos clínicos avançados em
homeopatia e faz uma grande abrangência,
desde câncer, pacientes em UTI,
pacientes graves, casos agudos, casos de
consultório também de rotina do dia a
dia e casos de pacientes autistas. Então
essa live hoje ela promete muito,
bastante informação, bastante
questionamento e a gente vai aprofundar
depois em alguns temas também. Então
muito obrigado a todos e excelente live.
Dr. Luiz Ter, você pode se apresentar
paraa nossa audiência?
OK, gente. Olha, mas hoje eu tô bastante
feliz porque eu tô fazendo uma live com
dois grandes amigos meus, tá? O Lucas,
que é um é um super parceiro em termos
homeopata, né? Então, a gente apresenta
congresso brasileiro, congresso mundial,
a gente apresenta congresso entendeu?
Mas em São Paulo. E a Lain Dutra do que
que eu considero um dos melhores médicos
ortomoleculares aqui do Brasil. Eu, a,
Alan, eu acordo de manhã, eu faço uma
esteeira, eu nado na piscina escutando
lives, né? E entendeu? Mas uma das lives
é é do seu canal que são 100 lives todas
que você fez de qualquer temas
diretamente ligados em termos à saúde.
Então aprendi demais com com as tuas
lives. Se eu sou grata, eu respeito
muito os dois médicos que estão aqui
comigo e e admiro muito lá o trabalho,
tá Laim? A nossa história começou há 43
anos atrás. Eu tenho experiência na 43
anos de clínica, né? Ou seja, a gente
faz uma ciência que existe há 230 anos.
500 milhões de pessoas se tratam no
mundo com o próprio tratamento
homeopata. Então a gente vai tentar
mostrar eu em 20 minutos, Alan em 20
minutos, o o Lucas em 20 minutos. Depois
a gente vai fazer um ping-pong sobre
diversas situações de CTI, de câncer,
casos agudos, crônicos e tudo. E eu
queria aproveitar dentro lá da minha
apresentação, eu queria do que que o
Alan falasse algumas coisas,
principalmente como é que é a inflamação
crônica lá da mitocôndria, como esse
quadro gera as doenças crônicas do
corpo, tá? E depois o Lucas vai falar
que tem muita experiência com o autismo,
em câncer também usando a planta que é é
uma planta mais moderna em termos
atuais, o visto com álbum. E e eu queria
que ele falasse dentro lá da minha
apresentação quando eu tocar nesse
assunto, tá bom? Então, Alan, eu aí
sugiro a gente começar aí aí a minha
apresentação e quando eu pedir vocês
entram, tá, Alan? Então,
hoje é o tema disso. Eh, a gente e a
gente, ela só vai correr um pouquinho
que eu tenho mais ou menos 400
PowerPoint. É lógico que eu não vou
falar de todo aí, eu vou tocar eh em
alguns pontos importantes, tá? E e aí
você pode passando, por favor, outro. Ou
seja, a gente vai começar falando um
pouquinho
de câncer. 8100 pessoas morrem por dia
na China de câncer, tá? eh os as
próximas duas décadas, os próximos 20
anos, 20 milhões de pessoas,
infelizmente, vão eh adquirir câncer,
tá? Então, eu queria tentar mostrar para
vocês como o tratamento homeopata pode
ajudar
nessa abordagem de câncer. OK, Alan,
passa para mim um pouquinho aí. Isso aí
vai colocando as setas,
tá?
você o que que a gente não
eu eu aí queria que você voltasse, Alan
aí, tá? Ou seja, o paciente que tem
câncer, a primeira coisa que que vem na
mente dele é um grande fantasma da
morte, tá? Então, o remédio meopá, ele
ajuda a lidar com a morte, tanto ele e
como as famílias também lidam com a
morte, tá? Então, a gente geralmente
passa remédio homeopata pro paciente,
mas a gente faz um apoio paraas famílias
que ficam com medo de perder aquele ente
querido, tá? E eu acho que o remédio
meopa ajuda na qualidade de vida lidar
com a depressão, a síndrome do pânico,
da morte, efeitos colaterais da
cirurgia, da quimioterapia,
hormonoterapia, radioterapia, tá? Então,
a gente pode atuar tanto no tratamento
primário, no pré-operatório, no
pós-operatório,
um tratamento complementar, tá? E em
casos aonde já aonde já tem metástase eh
super difícil, casos difíceis assim, tá?
Então, todos os cursos que a gente dá, a
gente pega pacientes filmados que tava
em coma do que que o remédio biopata
poôde ajudar a sair do coma. A gente
mostrou em São Paulo, a gente mostrou
aqui no congresso no Rio, os outros
congressos aqui. Hoje eu não posso
mostrar eh filmes, eu ainda não posso
mostrar vídeo. E a gente vai falar só
sobre casos teóricos, tá? Outra Alan,
por favor,
existe alguma
abordagem homeopata do câncer melhor,
tá? Então, o que que a gente vê, tá?
Eh,
o que que a gente vê nos casos é essa
abordagem é feita eh
com paciente que tem afinidade pelo
câncer, com com paciente que tem as
condições pré-cancerígenas,
casos a a localização primária, casos de
bastante metá. Então, eh, e a gente pega
casos que tem o sítio primário, mas que
tem metade em vários órgãos diferentes.
Então, ou seja, o que que eu tenho visto
atualmente é pacientes graves caminhando
paraa morte. Eu entro nos casos ou o
paciente, infelizmente eu morre ou o
remédio meopata ajuda a sair daquele
quadro, tá? Então, é, é, a gente vai
tentar mostrar algumas situações
clínicas assim, tá? Outro Alan, por
favor.
Então, algumas situações que o
tratamento homeopata ajudou do do que
que a gente vai comentar é essa paciente
aqui de cima que tem o câncer de mama
com metáde para fêm e metaste para
cérebro. Eu peguei ela dentro lá do CTI
e ela tava fazendo uma septicemia
importante ela no pulmão e ela ela não
dormia mais ou menos um mês. Eu
perguntei para ela assim: "Por que que
você não tá conseguindo dormir? Que
pensamento vem lá na sua mente?" Ela
falava o seguinte: "Eu eu descobri que o
meu marido tinha um contato sexual com
uma outra pessoa super amiga minha e por
causa disso eu tenho insônia fica com
mágoa, ressentimento imperdoável. Eu
fico pensando como é que eu posso matar
o meu marido?" Então, a gente passou um
um remédio homeopata para esse tipo de
câncer, mas a circunstância que tava
gerando o surgimento do câncer, o
aspecto, o desgosto profundo dela, o
sintomas mais emocional que foi a pista
para para mim chegar no remédio dela, eu
só não posso citar nome de remédios aqui
porque existe médicos assistindo,
existem pessoas leigas assistindo e pelo
o conselho regional de medicina, a gente
não pode citar nome de remédio, ensinar
nome de remédio, dando eh eh curso para
as pessoas que não são médicas, tá?
Outro, Alan, por favor.
Esse esse é um caso de câncer de reto
que teve com uma boa evolução com o
tratamento homeopata. Tem casos aqui que
a pessoa falou assim: "Olha, eu eu fiz
uma escolha, não quero fazer quimio, não
quero fazer rádio, eu não quero fazer
cirurgia". Então eu fui no Conselho
Médico aqui do Rio de Janeiro, eu falei:
"Ó, eu tô nessa situação, como eu posso
me proteger dessas situações?" falou:
"Olha, a pessoa assina um termo que ela
a pessoa ela fica responsável pela
escolha de de como ela quer se tratar.
A gente segue um grupo da Índia que
atende 400
casos de câncer por dia, sem cirurgia,
sem rádio, sem nada, só com o próprio
remédio meopa, a gente vai falar isso.
Então aqui hoje a gente vai dar uma
ideia que existe outras formas de tratar
o ser humano que poderia se juntar com o
tratamento oficial
alopata, juntando o remédio homeopata à
medicina ortomolecular, a medicina
integrativa, tá? Então essa é a mensagem
do do que que a gente quer passar, que
existe uma outra medicina que existe há
230 anos e todas as partes do mundo,
pessoas se tratam com isso. Nas grandes
pandemias, quando a taxa de óbito era
muito alta, tipo COVID, essas coisas
todas, a a as pessoas procuravam o
próprio tratamento homeopata, a
incidência de morte caía bastante. Então
é isso do que que a gente quer passar
para as pessoas. Outro
Alan. Tá. Esse é outro câncer de mama.
Outro câncer não. Isso. Sai. Volta, por
favor.
Câncer. Câncer de pulmão, que teve uma
boa evolução em 4 meses e o câncer
ósteo, entendeu? maissteossarcoma que
teve uma boa evolução em 6 meses. Outro
aqui é câncer, a base celular que teve
uma evolução boa em três meses. Então eu
eu indico para pacientes meus eh que são
médicos alopatas, a dermatologistas e eu
indiquei, mas esses casos para eles
verem e eles falam que a conduta em
termos alopata é só tirar esse tumor.
Então, eh, e a gente mostra uma outra
opção, o outra opção, tá?
OK. Alan,
um câncer também na orelha que teve uma
boa resposta com remédio homeopata.
Outro Alan.
Olha aqui
outro,
outro, por favor. Outro. Tá bom. Aqui é
não sai volta só mais um. Aqui é o grupo
de médicos indian outra. Isso aí. Aqui é
um grupo de médicos indianos do que que
a gente segue que eh o Shen Sancra,
Parec, Ramacris, Alabanergia, todos têm
muita experiência eh com câncer. Então,
a gente tem um intercâmbio com eles e a
gente estudou junto e e a gente
desenvolveu um approach parecido com
eles, mas com uma vertente nossa, tá?
OK. Outro, por favor,
aqui é é o grupo da Índia, aonde eles
atende 400 casos de câncer por dia, tá?
sem cirurgia, sem rádio, sem químico.
Outro
aqui é é um estudo deles, tá? Eles
trataram 22.000 casos de câncer, tá? Com
entre eh eh em 15 anos, tá? e tiveram
quase 20% de
eh de êxito
em em casos de câncer que ela tiveram
que tiveram melhoras, tá? Outro
tá aqui é um é um um outro estudo do
hospital no Texa, entendeu? Mas e MD
sendo Texas chegou para ele e falou o
seguinte: "Eu quero fazer um teste com
vocês. 50 pacientes de astroglioblastoma
grau 4 que mata entre 3 a 6 meses, tá?
Se vocês lá eh eh se vocês tiverem êxito
em um caso, eu construo um hospital na
Índia, eu dou 50 salários para vocês
atenderem esse grupo da Índia. de 50
casos, eles conseguiram em 15 pacientes
dissolverem o câncer, um câncer do
cérebro, astrogloblastoma
em pelo menos entre 3 a 6 meses. Por
causa disso, fizeram intercâmbio entre o
grupo homeopata e o grupo palopata, um
dos maiores grupos do mundo em termos
alopata MD Anderson do Texas. Outro,
outro
aqui. Olha só. Mas vê se você consegue
que ela eh eh para agora passar só o
iniciozinho desse vídeo aí, Alan,
acho que você não colocou para escutar,
Alan. Vocês
estão escutando o vídeo ou Não, eu tá
sem áudio.
Não, não, ela não tô escutando não.
É porque tá, eu vou fazer o seguinte, eu
vou eu vou eh liberar o altofalante aqui
do do sistema,
ver se dá para escutar o o vídeo. Pera
aí,
mudou o áudio aqui pro
aí. ele falando agora sobre isso, só um
pouquinho, só para eles escutarem isso.
Então, deixa, Alan, deixa então. Deixa,
depois a gente vê isso. Alan,
tá saindo o som aí, não, né? Não,
tá bom. Não, então não tem como. Pronto,
deixa.
Pronto. Pronto. Tá. Pula aí para mim,
por favor.
OK. Vou pular
isso. Pula esse vídeo. Então, aí é um
grupo em várias partes do mundo, aonde
esse grupo
mostra esse trabalho e e aí tá tá
fazendo esse trabalho em várias partes
do mundo, tá? Outro.
Olha só, aí é o grupo da Índia, esse
senhor de terno, eh, aqui do lado
direito e o e o esquerdo é o senhor John
Menderson, chefe do entendeu? Mais MDon
do Texas. Tá. Outro, por favor.
Agora interessante que eu aprendi com
eles e agora a gente tá sendo convidado
para estudar junto, a gente dar aula
para eles. Então eu eu aí cheguei para
ele, falou: "Olha só, mas como é que eu
vou dar aula para vocês se por acaso se
eu aprendi com vocês? Ah, não, mas o
aroach ela do Brasil é um pouco
diferente". Então, eh, a gente tá
fazendo um intercâmbio entre Brasil e
Índia de pesquisa e estudo de câncer,
tá? Outro, por favor, Alan. Outro.
Outro. Eh, e a gente vai falar de novo
em semana que vem para eles, tá? Aqui
são todos os livros do que que a gente
estuda sobre câncer. Outro Alan.
Outro.
Vamos embora. Olha só, emá 2000 no site
na Ciência Direct tinha 5.290
artigos de estudo entre câncer e o
remédio meopata. Outro
não. Aí volta um pouquinho.
Olha só, em 5 anos depois tinha 6.659.
Então, o curso do que que a gente do que
que a gente faz, eu e o Lucas, a gente
pega cada artigo, a gente pega cada caso
clínico, a gente mostra como a gente
chega lá no remédio, sintomas que a
gente pega, a gente vai, a gente, eh, e
a gente vai mostrar isso agora, tá?
Outro, por favor,
outro site. O G acadêmico, tem 72.
7200 pesquisas do tratamento meopata em
câncer. Então é muito trabalho, é muito
estudo, é muita coisa pra gente ver, tá?
Outro, por favor,
aqui um dos trabalhos do que que eu do
que que eu mais gosto, tá? Eh, no
ACC Camargo, eles estudam muito a
proteína PDL1 para suprimir a atividade
das células imunes no combate ao tumor,
tá? Então, o remédio meopata tem
pesquisa delas que ela elas estimulam a
apoptose celular, que é estimular a
morte programada das células ruins do
que que o corpo produz. Outro Alan.
Então, eh, a gente viu que um remédio
a carcinosina 30, ele estimula muito
importante a poptose celular da célula.
Outro
outro, por favor.
Então, olha só, a partir de 30,
mostra que já tá estimulando a morte
celular. da das células ruins do corpo.
E a coisa mais importante, preservando
as células normais. É totalmente
diferente a da quimioterapia, né? Porque
a quimioterapia,
felizmente ela é que ela mata as células
com câncer, mas ela ela ela faz ação
lesiva nas células normais também do
corpo, entendeu? Então é isso que seria
interessante associar o próprio remédio
homeopata, porque ele consegue, além de
matar as células ruins, ele consegue
subir o sistema imune lá paraas células
boas, tá? Então, atualmente eu recebo
muito cliente lá de médicos alopata
oncologista do que eles falam. O
paciente fala o seguinte, ele indicou
para fazer tratamento homeopata porque
os pacientes que fazem a quimioterapia,
a radioterapia, o pré-operatório,
pós-operatório, que tá usando remédio
homeopata, ele se comporta de uma forma
diferente do que que do que que não
estão usando, entendeu? Então, eu acho
interessante que os próprios médicos
oncologistas alopata e eles estão
indicando bastante, tá? Outro Alan, por
favor,
tá? Eh, ou seja, ela fizeram um estudo
dos remédios cacinosino, fitolaca, con e
tuia, tá? outro.
Olha só, e
dentro desse estudo mostrou que carcinos
fitolaca mostraram efeitos inibitórios
mais elevados, tá? Outra, por favor.
Tá aqui é um um outro estudo do do que
que a gente viu, a influência do
tratamento homeopatia clássica a
disjuvante no estado de saúde global e
no bem-estar subjetivo em paciente com
câncer. Um ensaio, um grupo, um grupo
francês que testou em 350 pacientes com
câncer de mama. Outro.
Então,
paciente esse protocolo.
Os resultados sugerem que estado de
saúde global e o bem-estar subjetivo dos
pacientes com câncer melhoram
significamente com tratamento homeopata
clássico, tá? Outra lã,
tá? Então tem várias pesquisas do que
que a gente foi estudando. A gente
mostra tudo isso no nos congressos, nos
cursos, esse curso do que que a gente
vai fazer com o Lucas, tá? Então, eh, e
a gente pega com calma cada pesquisa,
mostra em cima daquele remédio homeopata
do do que que a gente tá usando. Outro,
outro
outro, por favor. Ah, eu não vou
conseguir ler esses, tá? Outro, por
favor.
Tá. Então,
o que que a gente quer? A mais elevada e
a única missão do médico é tornar
saudável a pessoa doente, que se chama
de curar, tá? Então, é isso do que a
gente busca. A gente busca dar uma
qualidade de ver, aumentar o sistema
imune, acolher aquele aquele paciente
que tá sofrendo, acolher aquela família,
tá? Outro, por favor,
tá? Então, por que que as pessoas vêm
ela fazer o tratamento homeopata? Porque
tudo na vida tem seu alcance, seu
limite. Esse limite lá do tratamento em
termos alopata e os quadros estão de
evolução lenta, mas mais mas mais
arrastada. Tem casos que não tá tendo
uma resposta um pouco mais adequada, tá
caminhando pra morte. E a família
escutou falar sobre uma outra ciência e
procura ajuda de profissionais em todo o
Brasil. Graças a Deus, nós temos ótimos
médicos homeopata em todo o Brasil, tá?
Então, a gente tem grupos de de estudo
que a gente estuda junto, eh a gente tem
troca de casos clínicos, então
homeopatia tá muito bem estudada,
homeopatia tá muito bem estruturada, tá?
Outro
abre um pouquinho mais. Isso, tá? Eu
preciso conhecer esse ser humano. Eu
preciso conhecer seus medos. Eu preciso
conhecer o jeito de ser a própria
natureza deles, tá? Então eu preciso
acompanhar o filme. Nasce infância,
adolescência, chega num topo, se mantém,
depois a a gente vai decaindo ela
caminhando pra morte. Ou a gente fica na
cama deitado, triste, que um dia a gente
vai morrer, ou a gente luta pela vida
para ter uma qualidade de vida. E as
pessoas que eu vejo do que que são assim
mais felizes são as pessoas que
encontram a sua função na vida, o seu
propósito de vida. Deus dá a vida, ele
tira quando a pessoa acaba de cumprir
esse papel na sua vida. Outro,
o paciente, ele fala para mim antes de
surgir o câncer, ele dá pista para mim,
eu não tô me sentindo bem, eu tô mais
irritado, é um problema sensorial.
Depois o um uma alteração da função,
náuseas, vômitos e todos os os exames
negativos. Mas ele já tá me dando pista
disso antes de antes de chegar numa
lesão, um câncer, ele já tá me dando uma
pista do que ele não tá bem no trabalho,
ele não tá bem com a sua esposa, com
seus pais, os seus filhos, tá outro?
Eu
preciso saber o que que tá sugando a
força vital dele. Existe o corpo, existe
a mente, existe a força vital. Essa
força vital é que estimula o sistema
imune, que estimula a nossa vida. É, é,
ela tá sendo sugada pelo estresse, a
falta de exercício, vírus, bactérias,
comidas, eh algumas situações
emocionais, ansiedade, medo, cobranças,
culpas. Outro.
Eu preciso equilibrar um lado
autodestrutivo dentro do ser humano. Um
lado que produz as células ruins, um
lado que produz os pensamentos ruins,
mágoa, ressentimento, ódios, medos,
ansiedades. O acúmulo disso estoura no
corpo e na mente da gente, tá? E se isso
fica mais suave com efeito esse remédio
homeopata, eu eu consigo estimular um
impulso de vida dentro da gente que
estimula as células boas, esses
pensamentos bons, estimula o prazer,
estimula a vida, estimula a gente fazer
a nossa função na vida. O que move o ser
humano desde que ele acorda até dormir é
o propósito de vida dele, essa função
dele. Então o que que eu tô tentando com
remédio homeopata ajudar os pacientes
fazer essa função? Outro.
Ah, aqui é o pulo do gato que
após eu falar isso, eu queria do que que
o o Alan falasse um pouquinho disso. O
Alan tem muita experiência com isso. Ele
estuda muita importância da mitocôndria,
tá? Então, eh, o estresse da vida
estimula um hormônio cortisol que
inflama a mitocôndria, causando as
doenças crônicas no corpo. Então, aí,
Alan, então nós estamos sendo intoxicado
pelo alumínio, arênio, chumbo, mercúrio,
tálio, tá? Causando as doenças crônicas
no corpo, câncer, autismo, parxon,
Alzheimer. Tá bom? Outra Alan.
Aí eu queria do que que o Alan falasse
agora que ele é mestre nisso, estresse
oxidativo, estresse inflamatório
metabólico, que exames que eu tenho que
pedir e como eu poderia acompanhar um
paciente que tá com uma insulina alta,
homocisteína alta, na fibrinogênio alto,
como a gente pode fazer para proteger
essa mitocôndria?
Alan, você pode falar um pouquinho
disso, Alan?
Sim, sim. Eu vou só deixar o seu
microfone um pouco mutado. Se você
quiser falar, você só me acena aqui,
porque a gente tá tendo alguns problemas
de
eh de eco, né? Mas enfim, o Dr. Luiz
Terne muito gentilmente pediu para eu
falar sobre saúde mitocondrial. Então eu
vou passar algumas informações para
vocês sobre esse assunto. Bem, eu vou
começar com uma história que talvez mude
completamente a forma como vocês
enxergam a energia, a saúde e até mesmo
o câncer. Tem algo acontecendo dentro de
cada célula do seu corpo, nesse exato
momento, algo minúsculo, mas
incrivelmente poderoso, que decide se
você vai acordar disposto ou disposta ou
se você vai passar o dia inteiro se
arrastando, né? Então vai decidir se seu
cérebro vai funcionar, vai performar ou
se vai ter aquela sensação de neblina ou
de nervo mental. E pasm pode até decidir
se você vai desenvolver um câncer, um
tumor ou não. Eu tô falando o quê? Das
mitocôndrias.
E o mais assustador nisso tudo, a
maioria das pessoas anda por aí com
essas usinas de energia celulares
trabalhando a meio vapor, sem fazer a
menor ideia. Então, nos próximos minutos
eu vou fazer uma exposição, vou falar
sobre exames que existem aqui no Brasil
disponíveis para as pessoas e que você
pode ter acesso tanto os exames mais em
conta, mais barato, que o plano cobre,
quanto exames mais sofisticados. Esses
exames vão revelar exatamente como está
o motor energético do seu corpo no nível
celular. E isso aqui não é papo de
coisas místicas, é ciência de ponta
publicado nos últimos 2 anos. Então
vamos começar pelo básico, tá? Para
vocês entenderem de uma maneira que faça
sentido de verdade. As mitocôndrias são
organelas, ou seja, são pequenos órgãos
que vivem dentro das células e podemos
pensar nelas como pequenas baterias,
ou melhor, pequenas usinas
termoelétricas microscópicas que
produzem o ATP através da fosforilação
oxidativa.
Que que é isso, né? É um processo que
acontece aí na membrana interna das
mitocôndrias. que eu vou explicar um
pouco mais logo adiante. Então, cada vez
que você pisca, pensa, respira ou se o
coração bate, você tá gastando essa
moeda energética com ATP. E sabe quantas
mitocôndrias você tem cada célula? Muito
variável, né? Isso varia barbaridade.
Uma célula do fígado, por exemplo, pode
ter mais de 2.000 mitocôndrias,
neurônios pode chegar, até eu tenho
dificuldade de acreditar nisso, mas pode
chegar até 2 milhões de mitocôndrias.
Então, já parou para pensar por que que
o cérebro e o coração são os primeiros a
sofrer quando a produção de energia cai?
Porque são tecidos muito metabolicamente
ativos, são extremamente dependentes do
metabolismo oxidativo, ou seja, o
metabolismo que usa o oxigênio. Então,
agora vem a parte que tá deixando a
comunidade científica mundial de cabelo
em pé. Então, estudos publicados desde
2024 em periódicos como Cell Metabolism,
o Nature Reviews Cancer, o Signal
Transduction and Target Therapy e
ooscience. Então, confirmam todos os
estudos com cada vez mais solidez.
Disfunção mitocondrial não é só sobre
cansaço, é sobre praticamente todas as
doenças crônicas que você conhece.
Alzheimer, Paxon, Diabet tipo 2, doenças
cardiovasculares, fadiga crônica,
fibromialgia,
enxaqueca, COVID longa, doenças
músculoesqueléticas, enfim, uma série de
doenças. E o câncer também se inclui
nisso aí. E aqui entra um conceito muito
importante, fundamental, que não é
muitos médicos que falam ou discutem com
seus pacientes, a inflamação crônica de
origem mitocondrial. Então vou explicar
isso para vocês, como funciona, porque
quando você entende esse mecanismo,
muita coisa começa a fazer sentido.
Então, quando as mitocôndrias estão
disfuncionais, não estão funcionando
direito, elas começam a liberar
moléculas que funcionam como sinais de
perigo pro sistema imune. Então, estudos
dos últimos 2 anos que as mitocôndrias
danificadas liberam fragmentos de DNA
mitocondrial e espécies reativas de
oxigênio, que são os radicais livres.
cardiolipina, o próprio ATP, adenosina
trifosfato, o sucinato, fumarato,
peptídeos formilados. Isso tudo vai
parar no citoplasma da célula e depois
vai parar na circulação. E aqui vem um
ponto fundamental, o DNA das
mitocôndrias não é metilado nos domínios
CPG, como acontece com o nosso DNA
nuclear. E isso é muito parecido com o
DNA bacteriano. Sabe por quê? Porque as
mitocôndrias, na verdade, são
descendentes evolutivos de bactérias
aeróbicas que viveram há milhões de anos
atrás, bilhões de anos atrás, na
verdade, e foram pouco a pouco
incorporadas as células eucariotas, as
células mais evoluídas, digamos assim,
há bilhões de anos. Então, quando
fragmentos do DNA mitocondrial caem no
citoplasma,
o sistema de defesa, o sistema imune
reconhece isso como uma invasão
bacteriana, porque é muito parecido,
como eu falei, ao DNA da o DNA da
mitocôndria é muito parecido com o DNA
bacteriano. Então isso vai ativar
receptor stow 9, a via CG Sting e
principalmente o tal do inflamaçoma
NLRP3 que ficou famoso aí na na COVID,
né? Então, estal de inflamaçoma é um
complexo proteico citoplasmático que
quando ele é ativado ele leva a
maturação de citocina. São marcadores
inflamatórios como heterucina 1 beta,
heterucina 18 e vai induzir a tal da
piroptose que é um tipo de morte celular
programada que é mediada pelo marcador
gásm. Então aqui tem um problema.
Essa ativação do inflamaçoma mediada por
disfunção mitocondrial cria um ciclo
vicioso. A inflamação danifica mais
mitocôndrias, as mitocôndrias
danificadas liberam mais dumps, que são
padrões moleculares associadas ao dano,
né? É um tipo de sinalização molecular.
Isso vai ativar mais inflamação ainda.
Então é um ciclo vicioso, é um loop que
se perpetua. Então, pesquisas publicadas
no ano passado, 2024, demonstram que
essa comunicação bidirecional, né, dos
dois lados, entre mitocôndrias
disfuncionais e o sistema de defesa
imune tá no centro da gênese das doenças
neurodegenerativas,
cardiovasculares, músculoesqueléticas e
metabólicas. No caso do Alzheimer, por
exemplo, que é um tema a mim muito caro,
né? A disfunção mitocondrial em
neurônios e na micróga, que são as
células de defesa do cérebro, leva a
liberação do DNA mitocondrial que ativa
esse famoso inflamaçoma NLRP3,
aumenta a eteleocina 1 beta, esse
marcador inflamatório. E esse marcador
inflamatório aumentado no sangue, no
líquor e no tecido cerebral de pacientes
com Alzheimer potencializa a produção
neuronal do famoso betamilóide, aquelas
proteínas disfuncionais que se acumulam
no cérebro e induz também a
hiperfosforelação
da proteína tal, que é outra proteína
disfuncional que também tem na doença.
Ou seja, a inflamação mitocondrial não é
consequência da doença, ela é parte do
mecanismo causador. Então, em doenças
cardiovasculares,
estudos desse ano mostram que o DNA
mitocondrial circulante aumenta
gradualmente com a idade após os 50 anos
de idade e a abundância desse DNA
mitocondrial livre tá associado ao
envelhecimento acelerado, maior risco
cardiovascular na insficiência cardíaca
com fração de injeção preservada. Então,
o dano mitocondrial e a ativação desse
flamassoma formam um circuito vicioso,
que é a chave da gênese da doença. Em
doenças músculoesqueléticas crônicas,
né? por exemplo, a fibromialgia,
a disfunção mitocondrial nas células
musculares, nos miócitos, nos tenóos,
que são as células dos tendões, leva
também essa ativação desse inflamaçoma,
promove a tal da piroptosea, né, que a
célula, que a morte celular programada,
mediada por marcador chamada caspase um
e também a morte celular programada,
apoptose mediada pela caspase 3. Isso
vai levar atrofia muscular, degeneração
tecidual. A dinâmica mitocondria
alterada leva à fião excessiva, né,
destruição das mitocôndrias e amplifica
a produção desses marcadores
inflamatórios e também de estresse
oxidativo, aumentando a ativação, então
da inflamação. E olha que interessante,
quando você trata a disfunção
mitocondrial, independente da doença
específica, tem uma melhora
generalizada. E por que acontece isso?
porque você tá cortando o mecanismo
inflamatório pela raiz. Então, tem
estudos que mostram que intervenções que
melhoram a função mitocondrial, como
exercício físico de alta intensidade,
jejum intermitente, dieta acetogênica,
suplementação com alguns ativos
mitocondriais, como é o caso da coenzima
Q10, do PQQ, precursores de nada mais,
compostos em geral que aumentam a
biogênese mitocondrial, ou seja, a
formação de novas mitocôndrias através
da ativação da via PGC1 alfa. Então isso
vai reduzir marcadores inflamatórios
sistêmicos, vai melhorar várias
condições de maneira simultânea. Então
quando você melhora mitocôndria, você
melhora tudo na saúde das pessoas. Isso
explica porque pacientes que implementam
protocolo de otimização mitocondrial
frequentemente relatam melhora. E não é
só no sintoma de fraqueza, o sintoma
principal, por exemplo, mas em várias
áreas, mais energia, melhor cognição,
reduz a dor crônica, melhor o humor,
melhora o controle do açúcar. glicêmico,
melhor a função cardiovascular. Então
você não está tratando doenças isoladas,
como é o paradigma da medicina mais
ortodoxa alopata. Você tá tratando o
corpo como um todo, você tá tratando o
denominador comum, a disfunção
mitocondrial que gera inflamação crônica
sistêmica. Então, na prática, como você
descobre se as mitocôndrias estão
disfuncionais? Como é que você descobre
se essa inflamação mitocondrial tá
presente? Porque não adianta a gente
ficar falando desse assunto, né, na
teoria. E se a gente não apresenta, né,
como é que investiga, como é que
resolve. Então, na abordagem funcional,
a gente trabalha com dados concretos.
O primeiro exame, talvez o mais completo
disponível, né, no Brasil, apesar desse
exame geralmente ser mandado para fora
para análise, é o teste de orgânicos
urinários. Tem uns quatro laboratórios
brasileiros que trabalham com esse
exame. Não vou entrar em detalhes aqui
sobre isso, mas o exame mede mais de 70
marcadores metabólicos, incluindo
metabólitos intermediários do ciclo de
CRB. Cic de Crebes, para quem não se
lembra, é uma das etapas da formação de
energia na mitocôndria. E quando você vê
elevações de ácido málico, ácido
sucínico, ácido fumárico, ácido alfa
cetoglutárico, você tá vendo evidências
diretas que o ciclo de crebes não tá
rodando, né, funcionando de maneira
adequada, com menos produção de energia.
E o sucinato e fumarato elevados,
inclusive são reconhecidos como
moléculas sinalizadoras que podem ativar
vias inflamatórias quando liberadas na
mitocôndria. Então o investimento para
esse exame é um pouco alto, não é
investimento eh baixo pra maioria das
pessoas, mas é um exame que você é
importante você saber que existe e pode
custar por volta de R$ 2.000. Agora, o
exame mais acessível que você pode fazer
em qualquer laboratório é o lactato e o
piruvato do sangue. Isso aí o plano de
saúde cobre, pode fazer a relação
lactato piruvato. Então, quando as
mitocôndas não estão funcionando
direito, o metabolismo energético desvia
pro lado da via glicolítica anaeróbica,
que não usa oxigênio, que produz lactato
em excesso. Então, quando você tem essa
relação lactato piruvata aumentada,
especialmente acima de 20 para um, é um
sinal de que há disfunção na
fosfolilação oxidativa. Então, o
diferencial dessa relação é que ela
distingue defeitos da cadeia
respiratória mitocondrial de outras
causas de de acidose metabólica ou
cidose lá como a deficiência de piruvato
de deshidrogená ou piruvato carboxiláo,
onde essa relação continua normal. Esse
aqui é barato, geralmente custa menos de
R$ 100 e o plano cobre. Então isso é uma
alternativa para quem não tem acesso aos
ácidos orgânicos urinários.
Então tem também aquele exame simples,
aqui a creatina quinase que pode
aumentar com atividade física intensa,
que você pode fazer em qualquer
laboratório por menos de R$ 50. E se
tiver aumentado de maneira persistente,
sem explicação, que não tem a ver com
atividade física, pode indicar também
uma miopatia. mitocondrial. Então, um
marcador indireto, útil também para quem
não tem acesso aos ácidos orgânicos
urinários. Também você pode medir a
comenzima quedz no sangue, também um
exame um pouco mais caro, esse o plano
cobre. Lembrando que as estatinas, os
remédios que para combate ao colesterol
depletam com enzima Q10. Então, muitas
pessoas têm dor muscular devido ao uso
de estatinas. Pode ser por conta do
efeito colateral aí desse remédio,
abaixando a coenzima Q10.
Então esse é um outro exame disponível.
Temos também eh para quem tem mais
condição ainda, que é uma coisa muito
nova e muito sofisticada, é o
sequenciamento completo do DNA
mitocondrial em laboratórios
especializados em genética, né? Então
você pode eh verificar esse DNA
mitocondrial, que ele é herdado da sua
mãe, ele é exclusivo da mãe e você pode
avaliar mutações específicas que é muito
útil quando tem uma suspeita de uma
doença mitocondrial de nascença
genética, né? Então esse é um exemplo
bem mais caro, pode custar até R$ 10.000
aí e deve ser reservado para casos
especiais, né? E tem você pode medir
também homocisteína, vitamina B1, B2,
B3, B6, B12, ácido fólico. Tudo isso são
cofatores essenciais para enzimas do
ciclo de crebes e da cadeia
respiratória, né? Se você deficiência
dessas vitaminas, você pode ter um
comprometimento da função mitocondrial.
O magnésio que eu falo tanto no canal,
que é necessário para mais de 300
reações enzimáticas. Se você puder medir
mitocondrial, na verdade intracelular,
né, se vai medir o magnésio
intracelular, é mais preciso do que você
medir um magnésio sérico, porque o
sérico não reflete estoques
intracelulares de maneira adequada,
porque 99% do magnésio corporal tá
dentro das células. Então, se puder
fazer o magnésio intraeletrocitário
também é uma boa. E também tem os os
exames de aminoácidos plasmáticos. Você
pode tá verificando um exame chamado
alanina aminotransferase,
porque a elevação de alanina pode
indicar disfunção mitocondrial, e porque
esse aminoácido é produto da
transaminação de piruvato por essa
enzima. Então, estudos do ano passado
mostra que a lanina seguida de glutamina
e tirosina são a normalidades
aminoácídicas, né, dos aminoácidos que
são frequentes em pacientes com defeito
de cadeia respiratória.
Então, eh, existe outros biomarcadores
aí que acho que eu não vou me estender
porque são coisas que não estão
disponíveis no Brasil e também eu acho
que eu já até passei um pouco do tempo
que eu queria falar. E então, eh, eu
acho que eu vou passar a palavra pro Dr.
Lucas para que a gente não se estenda
demais aqui na live.
OK.
Você falou obrigado.
Obrigado. Eu só queria mostrar mais duas
coisas. Depois a gente passa pro Lucas,
tá? E você pode passar outro slide, por
favor?
Outro.
O, olha, mas o Lucas ele vai falar daqui
a pouco sobre isso. Ela fiz com ela.
Olha, passa outro para mim, Alan, por
favor.
Outro.
Olha só. Eh, e a gente quando pega o
paciente em coma, a gente dá importância
pra língua, a gente e a gente faz o
diagnóstico pela língua e pela pupila.
Outro, por favor.
Outro.
Ou seja, eh, a gente tá estudando,
entendeu, mais 8.500 remédios. O curso
do do que que a gente tá fazendo. A
gente vai apresentar lá 300 casos
clínicos e a gente vai estudar bastante
remédio lá mostrando a técnica, tá?
Outro, por favor.
Olha
só, mas só queria para mim terminar e
esse caso, uma paciente que tava em coma
com câncer cerebral, edema cerebral,
hipertensão,
entendeu? Mas intracraniana
e hipertensão arterial. E eu tinha
tentado 20 remédios ao meu pá até ela
continuava em coma. Aqui a gente não
pode mostrar o vídeo dela em coma,
saindo do coma depois, tá? E um dia
quando eu cheguei no CTI, o único sinal
que eu vi nela, tá? Era uma
característica da língua e o olho, um
olho, uma pupila parada e o outro
fazendo movimento lento. E quando a
gente for estudar, apareceu esse remédio
a pocino canábio, tá? Que a
característica dele que tá aqui na tela,
entende? Movimento do globo ocular, um
parado, outro fazendo movimento. Outro,
por favor,
outro. Então, essa é a característica
desse volta mais um, por favor.
Pronto, essa é a característica, tá?
E outro agora, por favor,
outro caso parecido eh de câncer
cerebral com edema cerebral. A
característica, eu tinha passado esse
remédio cardsulfúrio, que é uma pupila
dilatada, a outra pequenininha,
entendeu? Então, e a gente vai mostrar
no no curso A mentoria essa experiência
de 43 anos mim e a do Lucas também.
Outro, por favor, lá para terminar já a
minha parte. Outro.
Outro. Tá. Então agora a gente, ela vai
parar por aqui que tem
mais de 50 casos clínicos. A gente ela
não, a gente ela não vai conseguir eh
assim mostrar. A gente vai passar pro
Lucas agora um pouco, tá?
[Música]
Pode falar, Lucas.
Olá, pessoal. Boa noite. Deu certo aí,
Alan, o compartilhamento da minha tela?
Vou colocar aqui na tela. Deixa eu só
ver aqui. Eu tentei colocar, não
consegui.
Ah, OK. Tem que remover a outra
primeiro. Pronto,
deu certo, apareceu para todo mundo?
Tá aparecendo. Pode falar.
Tá? Então vamos lá, pessoal. Eh, boa
noite a todos. Esse trabalho, essa
palestra eu apresentei no Congresso
Mundial de Medicina Tradicional
Complementar Integrativa, que foi a
primeira vez que ela aconteceu na
América Latina. Ela reuniu mais de 60
países, inclusive a Organização Mundial
da Saúde que ela fez eh qual que vai ser
o objetivo 20252030. ela decidiu esses
objetivos neste congresso e eu e o Dr.
Luiz Sterni tivemos tivemos a o grato
prazer de ser convidados para ser
speaker, palestrante nesse congresso.
Quem fizer matrícula na nossa mentoria
hoje vai ganhar exclusivamente esses 10%
de desconto no valor total do curso.
Segue aí o Qcode para fazer a matrícula.
E quem quiser fazer pós-graduação em
homeopatia, tem também 10% de desconto.
Quem fizer a matrícula hoje tem aí o QR
code, fica o convite para vocês.
Lembrando que essa mentoria avançada são
mais de 300 casos clínicos, é uma
homeopatia realmente avançada. A gente
usa técnicas dos autores clássicos e
também dos autores contemporâneos. E
aqui também a gente tem curso de
formação em homeopatia na pediatria e eu
tenho um livro sobre febre,
exclusivamente sobre febre. E nele eu
falo sobre homeopatia, medicina
antroposófica e o manejo da febre. Quem
tiver alguma dúvida com relação à
matrícula, tanto da pós quanto da
mentoria, aqui tá o celular WhatsApp da
Mônica, que é a pessoa responsável pelas
matrículas tanto da mentoria quanto do
curso de pediatria para para médicos
homeopatas e também eh para médicos
pediatras e a nossa pós-graduação.
Entrando no tema, o visco álbum, que eu
aprendi a prescrever em 2017, eu fiz
duas formações e medicina antroposófica
e também existe o visco álbum
homeopático. Então aqui, como a gente
tem o interesse para saber de forma
geral para que que serve, qual que é a
utilidade, aplicação terapêutica, o
Visco Alba ele tem principalmente esses
componentes, mas ele tem mais de 100
componentes estudados, mas os principais
são lectinas, as viscotoxinas e os
polissacarídeos. Lembrando que as
viscotoxinas têm grande toxicidade
contra a célula tumoral. Eh, ela aumenta
a capacidade fagocítica do nosso
organismo e as viscotoxinas interagem
com a fosfatidiocerina fosfolipídica
ácida da membrana celular e modificam
sua organização supramolecular
resultando em sua toxicidade. Ou seja, a
viscotoxina ela ajuda, assim como as
lectinas, a fazer com que o visco álbum
combata a célula oncológica. E as
células tumorais expressam sete a oito
vezes mais FFA do que as células não
tumorais. O que exemplifica por que o
visco ele é tão mais específico para
causar apoptose e morte celular
programada da célula oncológica e não da
célula normal. Os extratos de visco
álbum eles fortalecem a morte, a lise de
células tumorais mediadas principalmente
por células NK. Lembrando aqui que a
célula NK é a primeira linha de célula
de defesa, a primeira linha de combate
do nosso organismo e demonstram matar
células cancerígenas em vitro, regulando
negativamente os genes centrais
envolvidos na progressão do tumor,
malignidade, migração, invasão celular,
como TGF, beta e metaloproteinases da
matriz. Então, nessa mentoria, eu vou
falar também eh em oportunidades ao vivo
com vocês eh sobre como manejar vis
álbum. Eu também sou convidado do
Instituto ITS Itamaçon de Ribeirão
Preto, onde a gente ministra anualmente
cursos eh de prescritores de vis com
álbum. Inclusive o próximo curso é agora
dia 1eo de novembro. Se alguém tiver
interesse, pode falar comigo que eu
indico o contato do Itz Maçon. Eu sou um
dos professores lá, tem médicos
oncologistas, tem dentistas. também,
porque o viscon é utilizado por
dentistas também na prática clínica. O
viscon, eles reduzem o potencial
migratório invasivo de células tumorais
e estimulam células do semimune, tanto
em vitro quanto em vivo. E as
viscotoxinas, elas são pequenas
proteínas que exibem uma atividade de
matar células e com atividade
estimuladora do sistema imunológico. E
as lectinas são moléculas complexas
feitas de proteínas, carboidratos que
são capazes de se ligar à parte externa
das células, por exemplo, a células
imunológicos, induzindo alterações
bioquímicas. Então, foram demonstrados
em ambientes pré-clínicos e ter outros
mecanismos de ação. Isso aqui é
importante, a antiangiogênese. Com a
antiangiogênese você impede que o vaso
sanguíneo ele cresça para dentro do
tumor e que possa nutrir esse tumor.
Então, se eu inibo a crescimento de vaso
sanguíneo para dentro do tumor, eu estou
favorecendo a saúde do meu paciente e
aumentando a chance da morte tumoral.
Então o visco álbum ele é citotóxico,
ele causa também necrose e apoptose de
célula oncológica. Ele é
antiangiogênico, ele é imunoestimulante
e ele produz betaendorfina. Ele causa
analgesia para paciente oncológico que
tá apresentando dor. Então o visto com
alba, a gente tem os principais, o
abnoba da que é feito na Alemanha, o
elixor que a gente tem no Brasil que é
feito na Alemanha, o escador também que
ele é feito na Suíça, também temos ele
no Brasil, o Vala da Alemanha e a Inject
Center que produz no Brasil o
viscoático, além de importar o escador.
Então, a gente tem disponível visco
tanto antroposófico quanto viscoático no
Brasil para ser prescrito, utilizado. E
o extrato de visco albo, ele pode ser
utilizado tanto pré-câncer, câncer e
pós-câncer. Aqui embaixo tá o número do
idçon, que é o Instituto de Ribeirão
Preto, que há mais de 50 anos promove
cursos em homeopatia e na hoje em dia
ela ampliou paraa área de saúde
integrativa. Então tá ali o celular.
Para quem quiser fazer curso de de vis
com álbum que vai ter agora dia 1eo de
novembro, eu sou um dos professores, eh
pode entrar em contato com esse celular
no canto esquerdo da tela que você vai
falar com Miguel, ele é o responsável
pelas matrículas lá em Ribeirão Preto.
Então, eh, pré-câncer, câncer e
pós-câncer. Então, por exemplo, a gente
tem uma hiperplasia benigna de próstata,
a gente tem paciente já curado de câncer
que quer evitar recidiva como tratamento
coadjuvante, tratamento paliativo. São
as indicações indicado para todos os
estados de câncer, em qualquer momento
no curso do câncer e na prevenção de
recaída ou segunda neoplasia primária.
Na Europa, o Visco álbum é extremamente
comum e popular. Ele é utilizado até
dentro dos hospitais pelos médicos
alopatas convencionais como uso
protocolar. é a planta mais estudada no
mundo pro combate ao câncer, é a que tem
maior número de pesquisa publicada e
principalmente na Europa, ela é muito
difundida e muito prescrita. No Brasil
ela é muito prescrita e difundida no
meio veterinário. Se vocês digitarem no
Google agora, viscum em câncer, vocês
vão ver várias publicações de casos de
câncer curado na veterinária e na
medicina humana. A gente tá disseminando
isso agora nos últimos anos
e principalmente o visco, ele causa
inibição da neoangiogênese, ele estimula
linfócito e estotóxico e célula NK e
principalmente apoptose, mas também
causa necrose. A gente tem melhora da
resposta imune a infecções, melhora da
recuperação hematológica, pós-quimir ráo
e pós-anestésica e ele eleva a
temperatura corporal demonstrando a
ativação. E e isso sempre ocorre, eleva,
a gente até explica no curso qual que é
a temperatura que eleva, por quanto
tempo essa temperatura eleva e se isso
persistir, o que que a gente deve, como
deve conduzir. Então, a elevação da
temperatura corporal é a resposta imune
organismo frente à aplicação do visco.
Redução da dor, libera betaendorfina,
como eu citei anteriormente, e libera e
melhora a qualidade de vida dos
pacientes. E agora entrando no tema de
autismo, é um curso que eu e a
professora Gabriela a gente dá já há
alguns anos, a gente já falava sobre
ácido folínico, que é o Leucovorin, que
agora ficou ficou popular por causa do
presidente Donald Trump, veio a público
falar dos benefícios do ácido folínico.
Isso a gente já ensina pros nossos
alunos há alguns anos, mas a gente tá
vivendo num ambiente tóxico, onde tem
toxicação com carga tóxica do indivíduo.
Dr. Alan acabou de falar também sobre
isso. E a gente tem, é, na visão da
homeopatia, isso gera obstáculo à cura.
E a gente pode remover esse obstáculo a
cura, eh, fazendo um protocolo na
homeopatia que a gente trouxe da
Holanda, eh, quem criou esse protocolo
foi o Dr. Tinos Smith, holandês, o Tom
Diansen, que inclusive tive já eh fiz
curso com ele, já conheci ele, tive com
ele no Congresso Mundial, eu e o Dr.
Luís, a gente tá sempre presente nos
congressos mundiais como convidado
palestrante. Vamos eh de novo ano que
vem pro México. Já tô em contato com o
presidente do Congresso para pra gente
levar a maior delegação brasileira da
história para pro Congresso Mundial de
Médicos Homeopatas, que vai ser emérida
no México ano que vem. E a gente leva
esses trabalhos. Por exemplo, a a os
estudos que que mostram que mercúrio,
chumo, cg arsênico, eles podem
atravessar a barreira placentar e afetar
o cérebro do bebê em desenvolvimento e
aumenta a incidência de autismo. A gente
tem aqui a exposição de mercúrio,
diagnóstico de teia em vários estudos
observacionais. A exposição de metais
pesados como arsênico, cámo durante a
gravidez pode aumentar o risco de
autismo em crianças. Ou seja, crianças
expostas, bebês ou intraúteros expostos
a metais pesados aumentam sim com
evidência científica, a chance de
autismo na prone. A exposição arsênico
em particular foi associada a
comportamentos semelhantes ao autismo e
modelos de animais, sugerindo relação
com mecanismo de ação. E a gente tem
revisões na literatura mostrando que o
bisfenol, distúrbios de desenvolvimento,
então eh plástico, tecidos de bisfenol
que usam são amolecedores de de
plástico. São essas garrafinhas de
plástico que contém bisfenol,
principalmente quando aquecidas, liberam
substâncias que vão interferir e
aumentar a incidência de TEA na PR.
Então os os estudos obtidos obtidos que
pacientes TEIA t menor capacidade de
detox natural do organismo. Eles tem
menos metalotioneína. O Tinos Smits
estudou desde 2002 a metalotioneína que
ajuda no processo de detox, assim como
glutationa. E elas estão reduzidas eh em
evidências científicas nos pacientes
autistas, tanto a metalotioneína quanto
a gluta isso tem evidência. Então a
gente tem que trazer isso paraa
homeopatia. Foi isso que o Dr. Tinos
Smith fez. E o Dr. Tinos, ele era médico
atomolecular na Holanda e também médico
homeopata. Então ele uniu essas duas
áreas. A gente tem o autismo, aí artigos
publicados mostrando que autismo pode
ser uma forma de toxicidade na carga
tóxica de chumbo e mercúrio. Então isso
que a gente vai mostrar no nossa na
nossa mentoria avançada. Aqui eu tô
trazendo temas, tô trazendo
questionamentos, instigando vocês a
pensarem, mas a profundidade da nossa
prescrição pro beneficiado, o último
benefício ser o nosso paciente para que
a gente melhore a nossa conduta médica,
para que o paciente saia do do nosso
consultório melhor do do que entrou.
Aqui a Grúnia, que é uma médica
ucraniana, ela não levou o mérito, mas
foi ela que foi a primeira em 1925 a
descrever pacientes autistas. Então não
foi nem o Kenner aqui no slide passado,
pois, né, o Kenner e o Asperge, eles
levaram aí o nome como os que
desvendaram e descreveram pro mundos o
autismo, os dois no mesmo ano aí em
1993. Mas na verdade uma médica
ucraniana descreveu isso em 1925. Então,
tudo isso a gente vai falar, o Bernard
Him e os estudos dele em 1964, ele
rompeu com a visão estritamente genética
do autismo. Ele trouxe pro mundo a visão
sistêmica, a visão global, a visão dos
fatores de risco e dos riscos
ambientais, risco biológico ambiental
pro autismo. E a gente descreve toda a
visão que foi desenvolvendo com o
protocolo DAN, que hoje em dia a gente
não fala mais em protocolo DAN, a gente
fala em visão abordagem sistêmica do
autismo, né, que envolve medicina
convencional, inclui aí o ortomolecular
estudado pelo Dr. Tinos Smith, Ton Diana
e homeopatia e nutrologia. Então a gente
vai ver aspectos nesse curso, nessa
mentoria, o que que a gente pode
melhorar na comunicação, comportamento e
interação social desses pacientes,
sempre com raciocínio uma base
biológica.
A gente vai explicar, o autismo, ele não
é doença, ele não é transtorno, ele é
uma uma síndrome, o que que ele é
atualmente a muitos autores estão não
mais falando que o autismo é um
transtorno, mas sim que ele é uma
síndrome, pois ele tem várias causas,
tem origens diversas e pode ser difícil
fechar diagnóstico. Isso é uma definição
de síndrome, não de transtorno. Então,
muitos autores hoje estão denominando
autismo como síndrome autística. Então
isso tudo a gente vai falar também,
estudos mostrando que inticida no sangue
de mulheres grávidas elevam chance de
autismo. E aqui a gente tem vários eh
trabalhos mostrando que inticidas
agrotóxicos aumentam autismo na prolle,
mesmo que essa gestante esteja morando
até 2.000 m da distância do agrotóxico,
eh esse agrotóxico pode causar autismo
na próle dessa mamãe. E o o autismo hoje
é 1 para 31, né? preciso atualizar esse
slide. Se não é o slide do Congresso
Mundial. No Congresso Mundial eu já
atualizei para um para 31. E a gente tem
na mesa integrativa, a gente classifica
em dois tipos de autismo, o intra
intrauterino, onde eh prevalece causas
genéticas e distúrbios metabólicos. E o
tipo dois, o regressivo é o mais comum
que a criança entre 1 e 2 anos regreno.
A gente chama de cérebro inflamado. Aí
como o Dr. Alan já falou da da
micróglia, a gente tem a ativação da
micróglia, que são as células imunes do
sistema nervoso central, que tem também
função fagocitária. A gente esquece que
a gente tem célula de defesa fagocítica
também no sistema nervoso central. Isso
causa uma desconexão funcional. E a
gente vai falar sobre a a poda neural, a
poda não realizada da forma adequada, o
que que é o assíndome do intestino
permeável e como melhorar isso através
da homeopatia. Vamos falar sobre
neurogênese, eh, migração neuronal,
sinaptogênese, crescimento de axônios, a
oligodendroses, eh, a formação de
mielina, de bainha de mielina, cada
fase, qual toxina pode afetar essa
formação do do cérebro e como tem que
ser feita a poda sináptica corretamente.
Os estudos mostram que autismo não é só
genético, mas ele tem o componente
também ambiental, que é mais ou menos
50% genético, 50%
ambiental. Aqui eu traduzi esse artigo,
a gente apresenta ele também nas nossas
mentorias, o que que é protetor pro
autismo e o que que aumenta eh o risco
de autismo. E aqui também outro artigo
bem recente, esse aqui é agora de maio
de 2025, onde esse esse essa revisão ela
faz eh uma abrangência muito boa dos
fatores de risco e esse artigo a gente
destrincha eles nos nossos cursos e nas
nossas mentorias. Então, a gente tem
muito artigo envolvendo inflamação
cerebral, eh, dano cerebral mínimo. A
gente tem essas respostas imunológicas
cerebrais, a MIA, que é o maternal
immune activation, por exemplo, mãe que
tem infecção durante a gestação, essa
ativação eh imunológica materna pode
afetar o cérebro do bebê ainda em
desenvolvimento. A gente tem aí os
estudos mostrando metil B12, como que
melhora os casos de autismo. a gente tem
aí mais recente ficou famoso pelo
presidente Donald Trump vindo a público
falar sobre os riscos do paracetamol que
a gente vem alertando já há vários anos
desde que a gente ministra esses cursos.
O paracetamol ele também aumenta a
incidência de TEIA. Então a gente tem
corticoides também aumenta a incidência
de TEIA, antidepressivos na na gestação
também. Então a gente vai mostrar todas
essas 287 substâncias tóxicas pro cordão
umbilical e dessas 217 substâncias são
tóxicas pro cérebro do bebê.
associação entre idade avançada materna
e o risco de autismo. Aqui a velocidade
intestinal e as fissuras intestinais que
vão causando inflamação sistêmica. E a
gente tem também a zonulina no intestino
e a claudina 5 que permite a barreira
hemato encefálica para ela ficar mais
permissiva à substâncias tóxicas. Então
no intestino zonulina e no cérebro
cloudigina 5. Isso tudo a gente vai
falar. Esse eixo intestino cérebro. Aqui
eu tô só citando vários artigos
científicos, principalmente da Índia,
que mostra um efeito terapêutico
significativo acoplando, eh, somando
terapia AB e medicina homeopática. Isso
melhora o resultado do paciente
autístico. Eh, os medicamentos
homeopáticos trazem uma melhora
significativa nos sintomas autísticos
individuais. Tudo publicação por equipes
de médicos da Índia. A referência
bibliográfica tá logo abaixo. A gente
tem também publicada na homeopat, né, na
Tem, que é a maior eh publicadora hoje
de artigos médicos na homeopatia. Eh,
123 crianças autistas foram tratadas e
mostrou a redução das características
autistas e a reabilitação da criança na
sociedade convencional e que pode ser
alcançada através da homeopatia
clássica. Outro artigo indiano, o pracu,
famoso parafuful da Índia. Outro artigo,
o tratamento homeopático é uma abordagem
promissora para ajudar crianças com
distúrbios do espectro do autismo e
atingir um nível de ótimo funcionamento
para ajudar elas a integrar-se a
sociedade ao sistema. Então tem vários
artigos que a gente vai mostrar também,
vai destrinchá-los aqui. Não é o
momento. Aqui a gente vai mostrar qual
que é essa abrangência da homeopatia. E
lembrando, quem fizer a matrícula hoje
vai ganhar 10% no valor total do curso.
Tem esse QR code e tem aqui o telefone
da Mônica. A Mônica é responsável pela
matrícula. O Dr. Alan vai est junto com
a gente nesse curso. Ele já tá inserido
e o Dr. Luiz Sterne é o grande mentor
dessa ideia que a que a gente abraçou
para levar o nível da homeopatia
brasileira a um outro nível. Eu, Dr.
Luiz, a gente tem nos últimos anos
frequentados todos os congressos
mundiais. tanto da medicina integrativa
quando a gente é convidado, como
palestrante e na homeopatia também.
Então fica aqui meu agradecimento
princialmente ao Dr. Alan pra gente
falar, a gente tá falando pro pro seu
público. Então eu fico muito grato de
pela oportunidade de estar aqui com
vocês. Acho que eu descompartilhei a
tela, não sei se deu certo, mas é isso
que eu tinha para falar, pessoal. Muito
obrigado.
Muito bem. Vocês estão tendo a
oportunidade de ver um material
fantástico aí da pós-graduação do Dr.
Luiz Stern, Dr. Lucas Mapacheco. Ele deu
uma parinha pra gente aqui. Eu tinha um
pouquinho mais de coisas para falar da
mitocôndria, mas eu quis parar para dar
oportunidade para ele falar e a gente
não se estender demais na live. Tem só
uma pergunta, sabe, que eu queria que o
Lucas respondesse, porque eu acho que
isso aqui vai ser muito útil paraa
maioria dos nossos
espectadores.
Você pode responder essa pergunta?
Essa pergunta ela ela é muito boa,
provavelmente ela ela foi feita por
alguém que já conhece o o viscum, porque
um paciente com doença autoimune,
provavelmente ele vai est doendo,
tomando um imunosupressor. E aí vem
aquela questão, o viscum como
imunoestimulante, ele vai ser antagônico
a esse imunosupressor?
Então, é um dos cuidados que a gente tem
que tomar nesse caso, nesse caso
específico que a gente ensina no curso,
eu prefiro o visco homeopático do que o
visco antroposófico, principalmente do
que o o visco antroposófico escador, que
ele é fermentado, porque ele é um visco
mais enérgico e o visco homeopático ele
é mais equalizador. Então, nesse caso,
eh, com doença autoimune, a gente ensina
mais e no caminho do ví com álbum
homeopático, por ele ser equalizador e
não tão intenso na questão de
imunoestimulação. Agora, um paciente que
nunca tomou visco com álbum e tá com com
diagnóstico de câncer e deseja se tratar
pelo viscum álbum e pela homeopatia, que
a gente pode inserir o protocolo
Banergia que o professor Luiz Sterne
trouxe pra gente. É, isso pode ser
feito, mas aí precisa procurar um médico
que seja capacitado em prescrição de
viscoal. No Brasil tem vários. E e esse
médico vai analisar individualmente,
porque tem tem vários tipos de de visco
que muitos pacientes acha, ah, visco
albo é só um tipo, não são vários tipos
de visco, tem várias potências de visco,
depende da árvore hospedeira, porque o
visco ele é o semiparasita, ele faz
fotossíntese, mas também ele suga
nutriente da árvore hospedeira,
independente se a árvore é um querercos,
é uma macieira, que é o malos, é o
pinos, é oas, vai ser vários tipos de
vis com mais ou menos concentração de
algumas substâncias como viscotoxinas e
lectinas. E aí vai ter a indicação
individualizada. Então o visco, apesar
dele ser eh protocolar, ele precisa ser
individualizado até por causa disso, tem
pacientes que estão tendo tratamentos
imunossupressores e eu não posso
atrapalhar esse tratamento desse
paciente e vir ter o risco de causar uma
reativação dessa doença autoimune. Então
isso precisa ser feito por um médico
capacitado.
Então, no caso, se for um paciente que
tem histórico de doença autoimune, porém
não está em crise de doença autoimune,
já está com a doença controlada, ele
poderia usar o visto com álbum ponderal,
digamos assim.
Isso. Isso mesmo, Alan. Isso mesmo.
Hum.
Perfeito. Então, eh, enfim, estamos pode
falar.
Olha só, mas eu acompanho o paciente de
câncer. e que tem junto um lupus, ela,
por exemplo, tá? E com uma alteração no
fígado e no rim. Após usar só o visco
alvo no abordagem homeopata,
a gente viu que a gente conseguiu ajudar
no câncer e todos os marcadores, todos
os marcadores inflamatórios do lupos lá
diminuíram após o visco em termos de
homeopata. Então isso que o Lucas tá
falando é super importante quando a
gente vai usar abordagem homeopática com
visco álbum e quando a gente vai usar a
outra abordagem, entendeu? Então acho
interessante e eh a gente no curso a
gente mostra casos que a gente usou
dentro da abordagem homeopata e o Lucas
mostra outros casos que ele usou dentro
da abordagem homeopata e não em termos
homeopáticos, entendeu? Não, eu achei
fascinante isso, né, de você ter essas
duas faixas de ação, tanto a faixa
ponderal, né, em altas dosagem, entre
aspas, e a faixa homeopática, né?
Ô, ô, Alan, agora a gente viu lá nos
últimos congressos em São Paulo, quando
eu tava contigo lá com o Lucas aqui no
Rio de Janeiro e e fora lá na Índia, o
pessoal tá usando muito vários casos,
várias doenças e a importância do dos
exames mostrando a inflamação crônica da
mitocôndria, entendeu? Então o próprio
remédio meopata atua muito nisso. Então
a gente vê independente da doença, se é
um câncer, se é um lupus, lá doença
autoimune, um diabete, enxaqueca
crônica, quando a gente desinflama a
mitocôndria, comprovando através dos
exames, o paciente melhora como um todo,
entendeu? Então a gente tá juntando a
medicina homeopata como a medicina
ortomolecular funcional. e do que que a
gente comprova através dos exames. E a
gente vê tumores, entendeu? Lá
murchando. Eh, a gente viu junto lá em
São Paulo, ó, olha só, mais vários casos
assim nesse sentido. E do que que eu
acho que eu fico muito empolgado,
já que tem eh mais várias pessoas
assistindo aquiá que são pacientes que,
infelizmente estão com câncer. um uma
grande esperança para eles que existe
com uma outra abordagem com menos
efeitos colaterais que se estimula o
sistema imune, estimula um lado do que
que produz as células boas, os
pensamentos bons contra o lado que
destrói o ser humano, entendeu? Então, o
que que a gente vê que o próprio remédio
homeopata com esses trabalhos
científicos do do que que o Lucas
mostra, do que que eu vou mostrar, do
que você mostra também bastante, Alan, é
que ele mata as células ruins do corpo,
estimula a apoptose celular e não toca
nas células boas, diferente das outras
abordagens, entendeu? Então isso isso
que deixa a gente bastante estimulado,
com bastante esperança, nessa fase atual
que muitas pessoas estão procurando os
médicos homeopata, os métodos
ortomoleculares e importante, entendeu?
Mas hoje em dia eu vejo para tratar o
ser humano, se nem fazer uma revisão
dentária como a gente viu em São Paulo.
E isso eu queria que você falasse um
minuto disso para você e Lucas, a
importância de a gente ver o aspecto
bucal dentro do acompanhamento do
câncer.
Alan, você pode falar isso mais ou menos
um minuto?
Sim, sim. É muito importante. Inclusive,
eu tive uma live com o Dr. Rodrigo 25 há
poucos dias atrás justamente sobre isso,
da importância da saúde bucal dentro da
saúde sistêmica, porque é uma coisa
muito estranha, né? É uma distorção que
a gente tem na no sistema de saúde,
assim, a gente achar que tem uma boca
andando sozinho na rua e o corpo sozinho
andando na rua separado, né? É como se o
dentista não fosse também responsável
pela saúde geral. e a gente como médico
não deveria também tá vendo as coisas
que estão acontecendo na boca. Então é
uma distorção que nós temos aqui no
nosso tema de saúde. Mas tem, por
exemplo, vários estudos falando, por
exemplo, que bactérias da boca
porfiromonas vaginales, eh, gingivares,
desculpa, porfuromonas givales, é uma
das mais famosas, né? Essa bactéria,
quando ela tá em foco dentário, por
exemplo, canal maltratado ou algum
processo infeccioso na boca, essa
bactéria pode gerar a distância, doença
de Alzheimer, pode gerar foco no
coração, pode gerar várias doenças
sistêmicas, inclusive câncer, tem
estudos mostrando que as bactérias da
boca consistose na boca muito acentuada,
isso pode gerar câncer à distância, além
de doença eh cardiovascular, doença
coronariana, pode gerar Alzheimer. Então
tem também a questão dos metais pesados
e os amálgamas dentários de antigamente
que tem três metais na composição, sendo
um deles o mercúrio. E a notologia
ortodoxa entende que esse mercúrio não é
problemático, mas sim a gente tem várias
evidências aí de que esse mercúrio ele
vai vira meti o mercúrio com ação das
bactérias da boca e com a mastigação vai
soltando o mercúrio e vai intoxicando
esse organismo. E também tem a questão
aí da ondas interferências, que é um
outro assunto também. E tem que também
pode causar problemas à distância. E
também tem o problema dos ncolos, né,
que são as cavitações que podem
acontecer nos ossos da boca e também
gerar um foco infeccioso à distância.
Falando rapidamente sobre esse tema que
ele é bem extenso pra gente também não
se estender demais. Olha só, mas só pra
gente terminar aqui como eu sei que as
pessoas estão mandando aquela no meu zap
aqui que que tão gostando e tudo isso,
pacientes, amigos e tudo, que esperança
do que que vocês dois, nós três damos
para esses pacientes lá que estão
sofrendo lá de uma doença crônica,
inclusive câncer, daqui paraa frente,
qual seria a postura deles para ter um
se por acaso o caminho que do que que do
que que eles ficaram doentes tá dentro
dele, que caminho do que eles podem
fazer daqui paraa frente para tentar
vencer e essa luta contra o câncer,
Lucas e depois Alan. Depois eu queria
falar um pouquinho sobre isso lá pra
gente terminar. Lucas,
esse é um campo que desafia todos nós,
né? Quem recebe um diagnóstico de
câncer, muitas vezes acha que aquilo já
é o fim. E a gente tem uma porcentagem
de câncer que são curáveis e tem uma
porcentagem de câncer que infelizmente
vão levar a óbito. Então é um é um
desafio para todo profissional que cuida
desses pacientes. Nossa função como
médicos, eu acredito que seja estudar o
máximo que a gente puder. Vejo aí que o
Dr. Alan e o Dr. Luiz Sterne são muito
estudiosos. O Dr. Luiz vai dormir de
madrugada, acorda de de madrugada para
estudar, sempre para resolver algum caso
complexo e grave que ele tá tratando.
Então, da nossa parte, como médicos, a
gente tá tá ali para acolher, para
acompanhar, para estar junto sempre que
esse paciente nos procurar e estudando o
máximo que é que a gente puder. Então,
quando a gente traz esses artigos e
inclui ele dentro do nosso raciocínio em
homeopatia, a gente tá tá trazendo o que
de mais atual existe, porque a
homeopatia ela é uma ciência ainda
tratada como dentro de uma bolha que ela
não interagem com outras áreas do
conhecimento. Essa bolha que a gente tá
furando, a gente tá aqui agora nesse
instante num canal que tem mais de
800.000 1000 pessoas que acompanham, que
se alinham com esse pensamento. E a
gente tá vindo falar sobre homeopatia
integrada às outras ciências. Então, a
apresentação que eu fiz alguns minutos
atrás, eu mostrei vários artigos não
homeopáticos. Mostrei alguns
homeopáticos, mas também alguns não
homeopáticos, porque todos nós temos que
ler tudo o que puder favorecer quem mais
importa para nós nesse momento, que é o
nosso paciente. Então, tudo que a gente
tá fazendo aqui, lives, estudando,
produzindo mentoria, pós-graduação,
coordenando o curso, indo em congresso
mundial, é para o nosso paciente, que é
o nosso objetivo mais importante, último
e é o primordial, para que ele tenha
benefício. Então tudo isso que a gente
tá fazendo aqui, o nosso objetivo final
é isso, Dr. Luiz Externo, Dr. Alan, é
beneficiar a qualidade de vida do nosso
paciente.
Alan, agora deixa eu te perguntar uma
coisa. Você é um médico muito
experiente, também estuda muito. O que
que você resolveu atualmente fazer um
curso para se tornar médico homeopata
também? Como é que você vai arrumar
tempo para isso? E
não sei porque eu tenho vários projetos
paralelos aí. Esse final de semana
inteira eu fiquei trabalhando no
computador que nem o louco aí. Mas vamos
lá, eu vou eu vou aceitar esse desafio
porque eu sempre tive uma curiosidade
grande homeopatia, mas eu nunca tinha
encontrado o momento da minha vida para
inserir isso, né? Mas quando eu te
conheci, Luís, eu fiquei muito
impressionado com seus resultados de
UTI. Então eu eu achei que esse era o
momento da de começar a estudar
homeopatia de uma maneira, eu eu uso um
pouquinho de homeopatia na minha
prática, tá? Eu eu aprendi algumas
coisas de homotoxicologia, eu aplico na
prática, mas eu não posso me considerar
homeopata e nem sei se eu vou passar ser
homeopata raiz, né, vamos dizer assim,
mas eu queria realmente aprofundar meu
conhecimento sobre as técnicas
homeopatas para ampliar ainda mais meu
arsenal, né? Então eu decidi assumir
esse desafio aí. Espero não decepcionar
meus amigos aí, meus colegas. Alan, a
gente tá fazendo o nosso melhor. Eu tô
gravando de 10 à meia. Eu já gravei do
150 casos. O Lucas também. A gente tá
pegando. É pena do que que não deu tempo
hoje para mostrar a história clínica,
que sintomas que eu peguei, um resumo do
remédio, um mapa do remédio. Então, a
gente tá fazendo o nosso melhor para
deixar esse legado lá pra turma mais
jovem, tá? Então, Alan, eu fico muito
grato, eu fico muito honrado de do que
que você tá lá participando desse
estudo. A troca vai ser muito boa, tá?
Eu tenho uma grande admiração lá pelo
teu trabalho do Lucas também. Então, eu
acho que a gente tá juntando forças com
um time muito forte. Se o treino é
forte, eu jogo tende, né? Se o treino é
forte, o jogo fica mais fácil, entendeu?
Então, a gente vai estudar 85.500 00
remédio. A gente vai fazer um pequeno
resumo. Eu preciso falar de três
sintomas para poder prescrever um
remédio bom. Eu tô sentado aqui, eu tô
com apoio na mão direita, a mão esquerda
e tô sentado. Então eu preciso, a gente
vai ensinar isso para as pessoas, como a
gente fez isso os os últimos 43 anos. Tá
bom, gente? Só para terminar as últimas
palavras aqui, tá? Eu só queria
agradecer a todas as pessoas que estavam
aqui presente hoje. Eu já tô recebendo
bastante zap aqui, é, clientes, amigos e
tu tá as pessoas gostaram. E e eu queria
só do que que o Lucas ela terminasse
falando um pouquinho mais do curso. Alan
também ela terminasse, desse as últimas
palavras. Eu queria só falar do que que
eu sou grato para Deus de dar essa luz.
A minha história começou aos 3 anos de
idade. As pessoas perguntavam o que que
eu ia ser quando crescer médico. Eu
queria ajudar essa música que toca há 66
anos dentro de mim, que me faz acordar
pelo menos uma, duas vezes por semana,
às 3 horas da manhã para estudar um
caso. Quando eu acho que eu achei um
remédio bom para aquele caso, volto pra
cama, em 30 segundos eu durmo, tá?
Então, essa música que toca dentro de
mim, o brilho que brilha nos meus olhos
é muito parecido do Alan e do Lucas. É
isso que move o Lucas. O o Lucas faz
cada congresso em São Paulo, se Deus
quiser, a Lã vai falar no nosso
congresso também, entendeu? Então, a
gente vai unir as forças e, ou seja, foi
um primeiro passo pra gente unir todas
as formas de entender o ser humano, tá?
Alan, olha só para terminar as últimas
palavras tuas. Depois do Lucas a gente
termina, tá, Lucas? Aí você termina, por
favor, Lucas. Alan, termina aí.
Eu vou colocar o Luiz agora para fazer
as minhas lives, que ele que vai
coordenar as minhas lives aqui, que ele
tá indo bem. Tá indo bem. Tô brincando.
Mas enfim, eu só queria agradecer a
presença dos dois ilustres convidados.
Eu aprendi muita coisa aqui nessa live.
Eh, fico muito grato aí pelos
conhecimentos que eu aprendi e realmente
eu vou procurar aprender aí esses
milhares de novos remédios aí. Vamos ver
se cabe tanto espaço no meu HD ainda,
né? Vamos ver. Eh, se Deus quiser ainda
cabe mais essa quantidade de remédio do
meu HD aqui. Mas é só agradecer a vocês
dois e espero que realmente o projeto de
vocês vá adiante aí com muito sucesso,
porque vocês merecem muito. Vocês têm
bastante qualidade aí do que vocês
fazem.
Então tá bom, Lucas, eu eu só queria
falar em público do que que eu admiro
muito teu trabalho. Eu respeito muito
você é um cara que tá mudando o ensino
lá do tratamento homeopata aqui no
Brasil, tá? O teu curso lá de
pós-graduação, eu indico, as pessoas
gostam. O que que a gente recebe em todo
o congresso é o quarto congresso teu,
cada vez mais gente, as pessoas amam. E
eu fiquei muito emocionado quando você
chorou lá no último congresso que
entendeu mais uma aluna tua, a Patrícia
dando uma aula maravilhosa, fruto de
tudo isso, entendeu? Então, é, é uma
coisa linda pra gente assistir. Eu
adoro, eu desmarco tudo. Eu quero estar
aqueles dias contigo no congresso. A
gente ficou junto aqui no congresso
mundial e foi ótimo. Ó, Alan, um dia eu
quero fazer uma live, eu, você, Lucas,
junto com as esposas, para a gente
trocar o ping-pong aqui, tá? Porque foi
ótima convivência lá, tá? Lucas,
eu queria que você me falasse, Lucas, eh
como é que é como é que é a tua jornada
de você dá pós, dá curso de visco albo
de autismo, fala em todos os congressos
mundiais, congresso brasileiro. O que
que você pode falar pra gente de como
vai ser a homeopatia do futuro?
Luiz, eu sou uma pessoa que minha mãe é
dentista homeopata, então eu fui criado
assim, meu médico era era pediatra
homeopata. Eu nunca tomei antibiótico,
corticoide, paracetamol. Eu sempre que
eu tive iotite, abidalite, asma, eu tive
febre escarlatina, tudo curado com
remédios homeopáticos, 100%. Então isso
me levou a fazer medicina para fazer
homeopatia. Então, já entrei na na
faculdade de medicina na Federal do
Estado do Rio para ser médico homeopata.
Então, tudo que eu trilhei na minha
vida, cursos livres, pós, estudos,
livros, eu fiz nessa nessa linha. Então,
é como propósito de vida e a gente se
sente muito feliz quando a gente
encontra com a nossa missão aqui na
terra. Dr. Alan encontrou dele. O Dr.
Luiz Sterno desde os três aninhos já
tinha encontrado que iria ser médico.
Então, reforçando aqui o convite para
todo mundo, essa essa mentoria ela é a
ela é uma pioneira no Brasil, não tem
outra nesse nível, que a gente vai fazer
encontros ao vivos mensais e mais de 300
casos clínicos que a gente vai abordar e
como a gente fez, que sintoma a gente
tomou, como a gente conduziu e como a
gente escolheu cada remédio para cada
caso clínico. Então, é uma mentoria
muito exclusiva que a gente junta
autores clássicos e autores
contemporâneos. E tudo isso que o Luís
faz, o Dr. Alan faz de ter várias
atividades, consultório, congressos
mundiais, ser palestrante, escrever
livro, artigo, dar aula e ainda tá
sempre produzindo, estudando, é por amor
mesmo. A gente faz por amor à profissão,
porque isso é muito intenso dentro de
nós. E o o dia que as pessoas entenderem
a potência que é a homeopatia e a
capacidade de cura que ela tem rápido e
profunda e permanente, as pessoas cada
vez mais vão eh se integrar a essa
racionalidade médica. Então é isso que a
gente tá aqui para disseminar esse
conhecimento que nos traz benefício e a
gente quer levar esse benefício também
pro próximo. Então muito obrigado, Dr.
Alan, Dr. Luiz e todos que estão aqui
com a gente nessa live. E Alan, você já
tá convidado pro nosso congresso e vamos
manter contato porque a gente precisa
unir essas forças que nós somos poucos
ainda, mas nós somos muito fortes, nós
somos muito estudiosos e a gente tem
certeza que a gente nasceu para fazer
esse benefício população. Obrigado
pessoal.
Valeu gente, Alan, obrigado aí pelo pelo
convite. Obrigado, Lucas, tá? E e eu
queria falar as últimas palavras para
aquele ser humano que precisa de ajuda.
Eu acho que tem um caminho saudável,
estimulando as células boas, pensamentos
bons, contra um lado que produz as
células ruins, pensamentos ruins. O que
sobra disso, disso tudo é a nossa função
na vida, o nosso propósito de vida. E a
gente faz um filme, nasce infância,
adolescência e chega num topo. Eu queria
tentar ajudar todas as pessoas a passar
pelo esse filme da vida de uma forma
mais digna possível. Essa é a função do
remédio meopata. Essa é a função da
própria abordagem do Alan. Eu indico os
eh
filmes do que que o Alan faz no próprio
canal dele, que é uma aula de medicina
ortomolecular.
integrativa. Eu indico as pessoas se
inscreverem. Então eu aí queria ser
grato aí para todo mundo. A gente vai
terminar agora, tá lá?
Tá certo.
Não, tô rindo aqui porque geralmente se
eu conduz as lives, né? Mas tá
conduzindo bem. Eu acho que eu vou
deixar você nesse emprego aí. Eu vou
sair desse emprego aqui. Você que vai
conduzir agora.
Aí do que que eu vou do que que eu vou
largar minha quitanda. Vou trabalhar
contigo e com o Lucas, cara.
Ah, tá certo. Pessoal, muito obrigado
pela audiência de vocês aí. Quem for
médico da área de saúde, por gentileza,
se eh tome aí as informações sobre a os
cursos maravilhosos aí que o Luís Sterne
e o Dr. Lucas estão fazendo, né? Então
eu só queria agradecer a audiência de
vocês. Até a próxima live. Tchau, tchau,
pessoal.
Valeu, Alan. Valeu, Lu. Valeu, Alan.
Tchau. Obrigado.